well part of Awakening is to be able to
increase the Consciousness enough to
start to see these Ripple effects
so it's not just about the immediate
action it's about what that action
creates in your future and in your
children's future and your
grandchildren's future the picture just
gets bigger bigger and then obviously
the action changes when that picture
gets bigger bigger so I was talking to a
friend about something similar to this
but it had to do with AI is that because
we just are going to be able to hold
more information more frequency more
data because in my in my psychedelic
experiences there's so much information
in there I'm like I can't like I need a
break
um I every question there's an answer
like it it's over overwhelming how much
information and so the what's come
through for me is is that that's why we
have to have amnesia and forget because
it's too much we'd like would short
circuit for real
um but my friend was talking about and
she's very spiritual and she was talking
about helping to create an AI that will
um be able to be an intelligent and like
a a good AI that would let's say when
you buy
um you know a glass for water like part
of the AI knows like the ripple effect
of what created the glass so there's
just more information in that so it
leads to a more environmentally friendly
a more uh informed
um and smarter choices moving forward
that are better for the planet for each
person for Consciousness because there's
more data and knowledge about where just
each and everything comes from so does
that make sense you're seeing the
positive potential of AI yeah but but to
increase one's Consciousness or
awareness to achieve a state of
Enlightenment is to increase one's
capacity for that type of information
which is why at a certain point you can
comprehend all your previous lifetimes
and you're not going to short sort it or
shut down or blow up I know we're going
to talk about ancestral healing a lot
today so I think that's an easy
transition into one of the first steps
in it which feels like reincarnation
like
and how what role that plays in it yeah
and how that even happens like the
pathway for reincarnation
if we're now pivoting from remembering
all of our lifetimes okay so so
reincarnation is very poorly understood
because what's happening with
reincarnation is a mix of free will and
determination determinism I should say
um
law of attraction in this universe
applies not just this one lifetime it
applies also to the cycle of
reincarnation in general
So based off of of what we are doing in
this current life we are a vibrational
match to in the next life
but it doesn't work in in all that
drastic of a different way than you and
your current life right now if I showed
you a person and I said is this person
making a choice
for the person that they're in a
relationship with
the answer would be yes that person
would be like well yeah consciously I
definitely am choosing to be in this
relationship or to get married to this
person
I could definitely throw a wrench in the
spokes though and I could be like but
what if I told you that the reason that
this woman is attracted to this man is
because he has all of the traits that
her father has
and because he has all of those traits
the minute that she meets him she feels
home now that's an example of
determinism so what we're seeing there
is that both are taking place at the
same time she's using her Free Will at
the same time there's a whole lot of
elements of determinism that are going
into that choice of partner and the same
happens outside of this cycle of
reincarnation so let's say that you were
you're standing in this space it's
really not a space we're just
conceptualizing of it this way but
you're standing in the space where
you're able to see all these potential
lifetimes you have memory of the
previous one you just came out of and
several more before then
you're looking to create expansion so
what is my path of expansion from
everything I've gained so far it is that
point of perspective that causes you to
choose into that next Incarnation but
you can only be a match to the ones
which are currently in your vibratory
Spectrum so
that has a lot to do with you know the
choices you've made in previous lives
and XYZ so it's a it's this beautiful
sort of coming together
of the element of of um free will
as it applies to the cycle of
reincarnation and determinism which is a
byproduct of everything that has come
before
do we actually
kind of remember our past lives maybe we
don't remember finite details and you
know so many things we can have
remembrances but but think but like I
think about old souls or people that are
just mature you know they just get it
they grasp it they grow like there's
just peop some people are different so
do we actually kind of remember past
lives totally depends on the person
where their aspect of Consciousness is
where their level of Consciousness is
I've met a lot of people who think they
remember past lives and they had no such
life it also gets more and more and more
and more and more and more complicated
when you get up to this this level where
this whole picture is taking place
because we like to think about ourselves
as like a clump of energy that comes
into a sort of meat suit over and over
again and that's not the picture of
what's Happening Here at all
Consciousness oh like water really what
is happening okay so I thought of it
like that but oh hell no so
Consciousness functions like water and
and if you're if you're taking like an
above uh look at a stream of water what
you're noticing is that there's all
these branches and all these splits yeah
Consciousness itself can split like that
it is a waste of time in this universe
for a clump of energy first of all it's
not a clump it's a stream but for a
clump of energy to come down into one
Incarnation and then go back up and then
coming down into a clump it's like a
waste what's happening more here is this
stream of of energy is coming down into
multiple incarnations at once so
the likelihood of there being many
embodiments for the stream of
Consciousness going you know creating
your
uh your awareness the one we're calling
Danica right now
um but likelihood of there being
hundreds of those right now
simultaneously walking the Earth is very
very high so you're all of them and all
of those are your past lives
you go even further than that and and
it's like we're just creating a
differentiation so a stream of
Consciousness that like what I call what
I would call Danica is a stream of
Consciousness within the stream of
consciousness of your uh Soul family
within the stream of consciousness of
source and and we are the ones that are
creating that differentiation there it's
a little bit like when we look at the
ocean and we see a current in the ocean
is the current the ocean yes so what is
it making it so that we're saying that
current is different than the rest of
the ocean
we're noticing and identifying some
something to differentiate that water
from that water it gets to the point
where we're like splitting hairs like
absolutely splitting hairs yeah
um
it is possible to increase one's
frequency to the degree where you can
you can track your passive progression
through multiple incarnations
problem is when you're doing past life
regression or something like that the
majority of people are not actually
recalling quote unquote their their past
life what they're doing is from their
current vibratory state they're
essentially being shown a life that is a
vibrational match to whatever they're
currently experiencing so of course it's
going to resonate
of course
um that's why it works it works through
identification right now I could go
higher than that and say that every life
has ever been lived is your life
because this is all one everything every
life has ever been lived in your life
people get lost in past lives and this
is why my focus is actually to bring
people towards ancestral trauma because
the way that they're thinking about
about past lives is in fact the way to
think about ancestral
influences
okay now decide the uh differentiate
that okay so ancestral influences quite
literally the biggest factor that you're
playing with here that goes beyond your
own current life like it it blows
in this past cycle of incarnation out of
the water
so let's say that you're sitting here
from non-physical perspective and you're
thinking about coming into a different
Incarnation what you're essentially
doing is watching
everything that goes into any of your
potential lines
so that means you're looking at multiple
parents
their combination on what month right
you're looking at the the entire
consciousness of every family line
that's coming into the picture of this
family tree that you're considering
incarnate into because you know that by
doing so you are essentially activating
and coming in as the progression of that
specific Consciousness so we do not come
here a clean slate at all we
intentionally come in
through that that story of that that
larger family line
and we inherit everything
um there is an aspect of cells that can
essentially choose into this that's the
witness Consciousness oh man I mean if
you really knew how much
how much what you're opting into plays
into the bigger picture of your current
Incarnation I mean people would be
essentially doing ancestral stuff
immediately what is the point of this
Human Experience
the macro point of life itself is a
human
it's progress self-aware
within the Universe At Large
perfect so
you choose dynamics that create
self-awareness
it's more complicated than that so
that's the macro picture that's what
we're all kind of doing here but it's
much more fun to look at an individual
an individual is looking when they're
coming into a family line for a win-win
scenario they're looking for a family
line whose expansion would be served by
themselves and that that includes that
picture of their previous incarnations
and everything that they've already got
in their Consciousness up to this point
they're looking for a situation where
they would cause that expansion by
virtue of incarnating in there and at
the same time there are detrimental and
beneficial patterns or character traits
or elements within this this family line
that serves the intention that somebody
has for their current life so I'll give
you an example
let's say you've got somebody who from
non-physical perspective is is very
intent on being a teacher right
that's one of the things that they
wanted for their expansion path I want
to be a teacher now it would make sense
to come into a family line where one of
those character traits is oration
where where you don't have as strong of
a fear of like public speaking
potentially or something like that
um but you're not you're not like
looking only at the things positively
you're going to get out of it you're
also looking at these negatives
essentially
if you if one of your intentions for
coming down to life is to understand
love you're not going to Incarnate most
likely into the family that understands
love you're going to be like oh right
I've come down here specifically to take
that one on to be the one that works
through that one and that's also a
picture of what each one of us is doing
in our family lines we are here not only
for the gifts but also we're here
because we wanted to take responsibility
usually for one major theme that's
happening and transpiring through those
Family Lines
so it's got to be hard right I mean you
gotta earn it everyone's going to be a
disaster
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen